morning now to the remarkable testimony
coming out of the January 6 Committee in
its second public hearing the panel
shared a video of a deposition with
former Attorney General Bill Barr who
said former president Trump in his words
had become detached from reality over
the results of the 2020 election Nicole
Killian has been covering this
investigation since the very beginning
and joins us now from Capitol Hill the
cold testimony yesterday was very
interesting yeah absolutely Gail and in
a 12-page rebuttal former president
Trump blasted the select committee as a
smoke and mirror show and a mockery of
Justice after it delivered a systematic
takedown of his fraudulent election
claims leading up to January 6th
I told him that it was that it was uh
crazy stuff what they were proposing
I thought was nuts pulled him flat out
that much of the information he's
getting is false one by one
Administration insiders like former
Attorney General Bill Barr told the
house select committee investigating the
deadly January sixth attack on the
capitol that they knew claims about
election fraud were false they claimed
they told Trump so and he refused to
listen I thought boy if he really
believes this stuff he has you know lost
contact with with uh he's become
detached from reality Trump's former
campaign manager bill stempion was
forced to cancel his appearance after
his wife went into labor but in recorded
testimony he said he warned the
president on Election night not to
declare Victory my recommendation was to
say that oats were still being counted
it's too early to to to tell
um too early to call the race and did
anybody who was a part of that
conversation disagree with your message
yes who is that the president disagreed
with that we were getting ready to win
this election frankly we did win this
one
on Election night Witnesses told the
committee the former president took the
advice of his lawyer Rudy Giuliani was
consider anyone in that conversation who
in your observation had had too much to
drink in the mirror was definitely
intoxicated but I did not
um know that his level of intoxication
when he spoke uh with the president
giuliani's attorney denied his client
was drunk the number of voter fraud
cases in Philadelphia
could fill a library in the weeks after
aides say he continued to push the
former president's baseless claims the
simple fact is that the Trump campaign
did not make its case still the select
committee alleged his campaign apparatus
managed to raise
250 million dollars off the falsehoods
which went towards a non-existent
election defense fund the committee also
alleged Millions were funneled to the
former president save America Pac which
spent more than 200 thousand dollars on
Trump's hotel properties and 5 million
to the company that helped organize the
White House rally before the riot Not
only was there the big lie there was the
big rip-off
some select committee members say they
haven't decided yet if they will issue a
criminal referral against the former
president to the justice department
attorney general Merrick Garland said he
and January 6 prosecutors are watching
the hearings Tony
all right Nicole thank you very much